otro como definiría usted la obra de La
nueva Premio Nobel de literatura
Bueno yo creo que no tiene como un
proyecto muy grande que es una especie
de auto sociobiografía que es a través
de su propia vida de contando su
intimidad contar la vida No y esa no
ella misma lo dice no una vida sino la
vida es decir atrapar todo lo que está
un poco a nuestro a su alrededor que en
este caso es Francia entonces contándose
a ella misma en realidad lo que está
haciendo es contar todo un país y
también en su caso sus circunstancias
que son muy concretas muy determinadas
porque ya es de clase Obrera pero a
través de la literatura de las
publicaciones sobre todo los estudios
pues asciende y se y llega la burguesía
no que eso es un tema bastante central
en sus novelas y luego Bueno lo que ella
siempre dice es que la intimidad y su
vida es una en realidad es un pretexto
para para la escritura que ella
considera sobre todo Una la búsqueda de
una forma
y cuál es el aporte de su obra en la
literatura contemporánea Bueno yo creo
que dentro de este proyecto del que del
que hablábamos contar Francia contar
también la vida de las mujeres es muy
importante forma o sea yo creo que es
uno de sus ejes fundamentales Pero creo
que es una escritora que tenemos que el
tratamiento del lenguaje y la manera en
que escribe es muy importante Incluso te
diría más que lo que está que lo que
está contando no su mérito Yo creo que
es
dar como un paso más en la en la
conexión entre la literatura y la vida
no como Cómo y también pensar la
escritura y eso creo que es muy
importante porque aunque como digo eso
ella cuenta su vida para contar un país
la escritura es muy pensar sobre la
escritura es muy importante también
dentro de sus propios libros Entonces yo
creo que el gran aporte de anigno es
como que abre puertas y que y que lleva
un poco o sea como que descubre caminos
no Y eso creo que es
los escritores que hacen esas cosas son
muy importantes porque no cierran sino
que permiten que otros escritores que
llegan después sigan explorando esos
caminos que ellos han abierto